uh so
today we are going to talk about the
evolution of water resources management
and at the end of the class you will be
uh you will be able to
describe paradigm shift and evolution of
water resources management in in general
but also you can critically evaluate the
importance of
iwrm for water diplomacy
and also water energy food nexus and its
relation with um water diplomacy and
also importance of water diplomacy for
acid being sustainable development goals
today's talk is regarding
a new process um recently a process of
water resources management and
sustainable
development goals and its relation with
water diplomacy
uh in this figure i try to summarize uh
from taken from this references
uh how the water resource management has
evolved throughout the time it has four
metrics you can see that from the
centralized management to this
decentralized management
uh in the vertical axis
and from centralized management it means
a centralized form of
governance where
stakeholder engagement and participation
is uh the possibility of
stakeholder engagement is very low but
when it moves to the
decentralized form of governance it can
include stakeholder engagement from
local peoples and local
participations and in the
horizontal axis you can see from the
supply side
management to the demand side management
in the
left
um upper corner
this is the traditional
development of water resources
management not only water resources
management any development started from
this side so it's highly centralized and
uh supply side
approach so
this is the first development pattern of
water resources so for example in this
case
only um
option is to invest
uh how to create dams
construction
preservers so this is the only
consideration for for the water
resources management and it's considered
only engineering based approach and it's
very technocratic approach without
considering societal aspects or
economic aspects mainly how to make the
development and how the development
patterns start and how the engineering
structures can can
can help to um make the
development effective so this is the
only only consideration in this phase
and um
then so this is the
position of a
in the left left hand side upper
corner and but slowly
it moves from a to b and in that case
the um
from investment oriented decision it
moves it takes consideration of the
societal issues slowly
and then
so initial um
management paradigm considers mainly
engineers hydrologists and technocrats
but slowly they can understand that that
this may create this can create
consequences to the society and they can
try to understand the demand of the
local
people
slowly and so they try to incorporate
the
uh they try to um uh realize that water
is not only the
uh
what are what is not only the um
development pattern or supply side
management it needs to consider also
societal and um economic aspect and thus
the demand side options um started and
demand side management started and then
slowly it moves to the sea and in that
case institutional reformation start or
for example decentralized form of
governance institution
and um yeah so um the
from
um uh engineering based structure of the
management paradigms
shift shift towards um
different
disciplinary bodies in the management
body but also
local engagement can also um
um taken place so this is the overall
broader um evolution of the water
resources
management happens internationally and
also many
countries so here i can give an example
how it happens in
bangladesh because i know
this um
uh the context of bangladesh water
resources management how it happens
throughout the
time so i can also explain
the graph that i have shown and what
happens practically in bangladesh case
so um
before 1947
bangladesh was a part of the british
colony
and um during that time there was no
embankment to protect
flooding in bangladesh so
um
in that time
local people manage the embankment
during the um
dry season to um
grow the
crops and in that case landlords
the
british empire provide um
ownership to the landlord to manage
a specific area of land and through
engaging local farmers
the landlords um
was was responsible for
managing flood protection embankments
only during the
um dry season for growing crops
but during rainy season that embankment
was um
yeah
vanished because of the um rainfall and
the river water could enter into the
flood plain and it helps sedimentation
and it it increases the uh yeah so land
formation
was happening during that time because
sediment could
come into the uh flood plain
and so this is kind of um natural
process was maintained during that
period but after 1947 the british colony
ended and there is no institution like
the
landlord management
territory was not there and
since then um
this
part of land was was part of indian
um state so um
it was um
so india and pakistan was divided and
bangladesh was part of the east pakistan
during that time
and
so during that time there was no
responsible authority to managing the
embankment or flood plain
and
during that time in 1954 and 55 there
was a
major flood events
and after that flood events
flood
protection embankments was um
constructed in 1960s
and you see the during that
pre-order heavy engineering works
started
and and in that case the embankment
protect the flooding
uh from the um
uh
river but also um um
it it it helps initially the
agricultural uh production highly
uh but slowly after few years
uh you know
this is um this uh this
river um carries huge amount of sediment
and that's sediment
deposited in the flood plain and that
makes the land formation in the flood
plain but due to the embankment this
process was um was not taken place due
to the construction of the embankment
and then the um
sedimentation was happening in the river
fed a riverbed instead of the floodplain
so the floodplain ah the land formation
was not happening in the flood plain but
those um sedimentation um
was
those sediment was deposited in the
riverbed and that increased the riverbed
and it reduces the navigability at the
same time
the internal water logging started so in
1980s this whole area of floodplain
becomes waterlogged and permanent
flooding was
happening because of this construction
of uh embankment so you see how the
consequence started from the supply side
approach um without considering without
uh considering only the narrow focus of
the supply side
process so initially it helps in
improving the agricultural production
but
in the long run it it created
a disaster to the local
people so local people understood this
process
and they
really understood the
what is happening there so
going against against the
government they try to cut the
embankment and
bring the river water inside the flood
plain and this process they call this is
tidal river management in 1990s
so they try to implement this
process going against uh government
process and they try to implement
locally
with self-organizing
capacity and that they implemented in
one
flood plain and they were successful and
they um after uh
two years they were able to um see the
major impact like um navigability of uh
in the riverbed um
um
is increased and also um
the flood plain the sedimentation was
happening in the flood plain so um then
the
government could also see the positive
benefits so then they try to
institutionalize this approach in the
in the
government approach so how you can see
how the transformation or evolution
happened in in this
context uh similar explanation that i
just gave in the in the
previous slide
just to show how how the evolution was
uh happening
i uh also try to explain uh how
paradigm shift in um water resources
management um happened through the
literature provided by claudia paul
boson um she's one of the
um yeah
[Music]
experts on adaptive water resource
management or integrated water resources
management and um
so in her work um she tried to um
yeah
categorize or explain different
dimensions of
um
order resources management from
control um command and control approach
to the integrated approach so in the
governance dimensions that the major
paradigm shift happened from centralized
form of governance to the to the
uh polycentric form of governance um
incorporates both integration of top
down and bottom-up approach
and also in terms of sectoral
integration in in the case of um
command and controller proofs um
um in that case the
sectoral integration was not possible
and it cares policy conflicts but in the
integrated
uh form integrated and adaptive form of
management the cross sectoral
integration
is possible and um
that that also integrates policy
implementation
so um
in the case of
scale of analysis and
operations this transboundary problems
emerge when
river sub-basins are exclusive scale of
analysis and
management
but in the integrated form of
governance the trans-boundary issues
addressed by multiple scale of analysis
and
management
and in the case of information
management
understanding fragmented by gaps and
lack of integration of appropriated or
proprietary
information sources
but in the case of integrated form of
governance
uh this comprehensive understanding
achieved by
open shared information sources that
fill
gaps and facilitate integration
and um there are also three other
dimensions so as
infrastructure you can see that um in in
the first cases only the command and
controller pros um
massive centralized infrastructure
design and
engineering based structure is
dominant but in the case of integrative
um integrative and adaptive water
resource management
this incorporates combination of
centralized and decentralized diverse
source of
design and power
delivery is very important
and in terms of financial and risk um
management this this case is only
structural protection and its risks are
considered but in the case of
integrative management diversified
financial resources are
considered for um
by considering broad set of
private and public financial
instruments
and important aspect is dealing with
uncertainty in the case of command and
control approach it is considered that
um
uncertainty is considered as undesirable
sign of incomplete knowledge so they
don't know what will happen and how to
manage the uncertainty
and uh this will create major problem
but adaptive and integrative
management um
the
irreducible uncertainties are acceptable
and the adaptive approach are taken how
to deal with the fuse or uncertain
outcomes uh by considering different
different uh scenarios for example
uh different
perspectives of explicit um different
perspective perspectives are explicitly
acknowledged so here you can see
uh
differentiation um difference between
the
two approaches from command and control
to the integrated approach so now uh we
would like to introduce one of the
major paradigm shift and major dominant
um paradigm of water resource management
which is integrated water resources
management
and of course this this falls in the
uh right hand side the characteristics
that i have uh shown here so integrative
and integrated water resources uh
management
integrated water resources management is
not new although the is international is
um
conceptualized recently in
the
um
20th century and at the end of 20th
century it's introduced in the
international arena but
um
there are ancient
practices that incorporates that into
integrated the major dimensions of
integrated water resources management
has been
considered for example in 9th century
subak irrigation system in
bali
is one of the ancient irrigation
practices which um
practice this integrated water resources
management of course without knowing the
concept but that they try to incorporate
the um integration self-organization for
um
managing the
bali irrigation systems through ancient
um
practices here i wanted to share an
a video very short
video but you can find interesting how
they were able to manage this um
super irrigation
system in in the balinese agricultural
practices
so let me share this
you can see how self-organization and um
cooperative management of um um
cooperative water management has taken
place since
that ancient
time and
and not only the
um subway system but also there are
other
um
historical practices that incorporates
this integrated form of
resource management practices and other
water resources management practices in
valencia spain
the multi-stakeholder
participatory water tribunal have
operated at least since 10th century
but but also um
the
modern form of integrated water
resources
management was influenced mainly by
authority created in 1933
to holistically manage water
resources so
um i i don't know whether uh you are
familiar with the
uh tennessee valley authority did some
of you are familiar with this
uh
larry do you know
um
i i know some
information but
probably you know better than me uh
regarding the dba form of
management approach
well tba wasn't just set up as a water
management
body the tennessee valley authority
had enormous scope
of development
power and responsibility
and one of the few times
in the united states where
there was development across a large
region
more than just a city or a metropolitan
area this covered much more of an area
and it attempted to give
public management
to infrastructure
at a scale
that the united states wasn't used to
and
it
as you as you point out it was
credited
with being a planning
mechanism
but given how anti-planning the united
states has always been
i think it's more
helpful to think about it as a
development mechanism
and
we had and still have but we had then
lagging regions in terms of economic
development
and the strategy was
let's make a massive
investment
in a lagging region
let's have
all of the infrastructure
roads that connected to
other places
water that it needs electricity or
hydropower that it needs let's have
all of the infrastructure done
simultaneously
and let's invest
government funding
at a large enough scale that it would
then promote
subsequent private investment and make
it a sustainable place
but with a
much larger role for government
managed infrastructure
on
that never took off as an idea we don't
see other regions
of the united states where lagging areas
were um
targeted by an economic development
strategy that said let's have a massive
public investment in all of the
infrastructure
job creation training
and let's not worry about state and
local government and uh
let's do it at a scale that turns around
the lagging region because smaller scale
efforts to turn around lagging regions
don't work
so
the way to understand this the tva story
and there are many books
written about tva
sort of longing for
a regional publicly managed
massive infrastructure
project
that would uh stimulate the economy in a
way that wouldn't happen otherwise
yeah yeah so um
yeah also in the iwrm
literacy uh globally this um
tba approach is highly acknowledged and
uh it says that the tbl like approach um
mushroomed all over the world for um
developing mainly agricultural
development in the developing country so
um that that
culture has has been practiced is is
also um
in um other
places and the regional development plan
through incorporating for example um
power generation flood control
and how this integration happens um and
also the concept
integration of multiple sectors
uh in the iwrm also uh camp uh from this
tv like approach that is um uh mentioned
in the iwrm literature
yeah so uh before going to
principles maybe we can um
have a
participatory discussion here um why
iwrm is important for water diplomacy in
your
opinion i i wanted to make it a breakout
group but as we are only
five people so maybe we can
discuss why in your opinion also there
was a memo question on this so maybe we
can discuss here
discuss here why iwrm is important for
water diplomacy
well i guess first do you think it is
what what is it about
integrated
management of water resources
that makes it an important
element
of
dealing with transboundary waters
this is a little bit of low-hanging
fruit but one of the readings observed
that it's the dominant paradigm for
water management globally
so it sort of
is therefore
important to diplomacy but i think one
of the other things that
stood out to me and i wrote a little bit
about this in my in my memo is just
sort of
efforts to move beyond diplomatic silos
um there's there was an example in the
loop at all piece that like really stood
out to me about biofuels and how like
the development of biofuels
sort of subsequently catalyzed or
exacerbated existing problems with water
and food scarcity so the need for like a
more integration a more integrated
management approach felt
sort of urgent and necessary as we as we
move towards perhaps greater scarcity in
certain water systems
but how would that work or theoretically
how might that work
in context in which
we do have siloed
entities responsible for things like
water
and if you say
well integrated
management is the key
to managing water in the future so that
you can connect
water with energy with food with land
but that's not how those
entities are set up
right yeah is it aren't we basically
setting
up
to setting up systems to fail
if we say that they have to be
integrated in order to do water
management when we know that they're not
therefore what are we hoping for
that is a good question
i don't know if i have an immediate
answer i'll think about that though well
i'm not sure there's a right answer yes
uh it seems to me that
from a from a planning perspective urban
regional planning perspective not a
water perspective
there's always an argument for centuries
that the way to plan cities effectively
is to start with a clean
empty area
and have a designer make a comprehensive
integrated plan
so that the land is used efficiently so
that all the uses are appropriately laid
out and
separate from each other when that's
appropriate
and that um you don't have to
have holes in the plan
where there's private ownership or other
things that happen and you don't have to
worry over time because you just started
building in one corner and by the time
it was done it was just a giant
pattern that's uh of uncontrolled
development the idea has always been
you should plan whole cities in a
comprehensive way to me
iwrm has some of the same resonance okay
now we know in real life there are very
very few
planned cities where the whole city was
laid out
and
all of its evolution was guided by or
controlled by the original plan
and
it's very hard to have in a democratic
context and one in which there's private
land ownership
continuity
with a single plan
and even in some parts of the world
where historically there were efforts to
plan
whole new capitals whole new cities
where they brought in a famous architect
who made a beautiful plan for the whole
place
over decades
the place changes from what the original
design was
for all kinds of reasons not the least
of which people want to have choice
about what things are going to be look
like and what it can do with what their
land is and what say they have in a
democratic context
so
just for purposes of of uh
pursuing further the question that i
asked you gemma is
um do you imagine that people in a
democratic context
can live in in and work and build in a
way that's comprehensive
integrated and planned
when all the forces of democracy
privatization
individuality and all the unexpected
things that happen
or organically
pull in the opposite direction
i mean i think i have to say yes but
that's sort of my prerogative as a first
semester urban planning student like if
you i've already given up on the field
then it may be too late for me
um
i think that
some healthy skepticism isn't uncalled
for i guess i mean it's
i don't know i guess it's
what is sort of resonant about iwrm and
like the water nexus approach and like
sort of
science policy interfaces more broadly
is the
kind of potential to reimagine existing
diplomatic regimes but i don't know
whether that actually will work in
practice
so maybe it's just an intellectual
exercise but i think it's a useful
intellectual exercise
well it's only useful if it inspires
something in practice that can be done
right it's not useful
if it alludes to something in theory
that can't be done in practice and
everybody's just thwarted
and can't achieve what they're supposed
to or the ideal
and
just to come to to loop back around
again to urban planning nobody in urban
planning teaches about comprehensive
planned cities anymore except as a
intriguing historical artifact
nobody would imagine
that you would build a place according
to a plan at time one and expect at time
two a decade two decades a century later
that the place is going to have anything
to do with what that original plan was
and yet they still think there's
planning going on
the plan the planning
is about the process of
is but the process of adaptation
yeah the planning is to create the
institutions to be able to modify
what you're doing collectively
so it's it's still planning
it's not planning it to achieve a
pre-ordained comprehensive idea
and i would argue in the water realm
we ought to be worried about iwrm as an
ideal
because it presumes there are
institutions with the authority
the power with the knowledge
to integrate across
all of these multiple dimensions in
spite of the fact that we have created
the silos that you alluded to
and that there are contending interests
trying to pursue and maximize different
outcomes
for from their standpoint that are good
from their standpoint
so for the reasons i worry about
comprehensive planning i worry about
iwrm
so any other thoughts
regarding iworm
i think something related to what we
were just talking about is like the
interesting fact that in some ways the
iwrm is like very broad but then in
other ways a lot of people criticize it
for not being broad enough
um saying that like the adaptive water
management system like needs to replace
or augment the iwrm because that um is
moving toward
that like can we not only create water
management but can we make sure that
this water management system is also
going to be adaptable to the future
because we have to assume that it's not
constant when we look at these extreme
weather patterns or
um like changes in the nature of a
conflict some of these iwrm
um like
management scenarios are just not
like actively trying to adapt and become
better to adjust to these changes so in
a lot of ways people are saying like oh
the iwrm is not enough like what about
the nexus what about this like adaptive
water management system and so like in
my memo i talked a lot about how um i
think one of the readings tried to
analyze whether or not like you could
replace the iwrm and i thought it was
really interesting that they touched on
like the social value of the iwrm like
it's taken a long time to be adopted
because
like a lot of the water policy
water diplomacy sector is like
if well-respected water diplomats use a
certain water management system then
like it's more likely to be somewhere
else not just
i guess like how some business models or
other like sectors might transfer a
certain system so i just think that the
the iwrms
value the fact that it is water centric
is like i think very
like a strength of the iwrm and then the
fact that in the nexus water is um not
considered more valuable or important
than these other
like sectors that you're considering in
the nexus whether or not it's like the
food water energy nexus where like every
sector needs to be treated equally i
think like the fact that the iwrm puts
the water
like
as the most important entity even though
it is maybe creating some boundaries
that the nexus wants to like get rid of
i think is still really valuable because
if you like
get too broad it's hard to make any
progress
but maybe i've misinterpreted
i don't know it seems like the future
needs to be like more understanding and
expansive and multi-centric but also
like
how do we make progress if we can't get
all those people to sit at the table and
make an agreement in any regard
yeah i think uh in terms of um
theoretical aspect of course the iwrm is
very interesting and but in terms of
practice um this is the main limitations
that to
uh implement this theoretical framework
in practice this is highly
criticized and
this um implementation
um through um
actual uh following the actual process
of the framework i i haven't done
uh i haven't seen any um
studies that really went through the
iwrm implementation
so that is the main challenging thing
that the implementation of iwrm
is
is very difficult and is
is one of the
um
unachieved goal of the iwrm that's the
main
criticism but in terms of the
uh theoretical contribution that has
been done is i think is
highly valuable at the broader level
but for implementing uh it needs kind of
um yeah
some kind of um implementation oriented
approach
that's how i i see
so yeah
any thought at all in practice i mean i
guess i mean
in practice i guess you would hope
that negotiators would
would have enough or be able to bring
enough i mean this is obviously very
dependent on on what the kind of
initiating circumstances are of any
negotiation but have enough flexibility
to
to draw upon kind of various
frameworks
as they
as needed as as beneficial to
a specific dispute whether or not you
know they call it iwrm
um
or not
you know the limitations of the iwrm
whether it's in terms of scale or in
terms of of kind of what's not included
because of its water centric focus like
can be supplemented by drawing off some
of the other nexus
some of the next approaches as you know
the other others have said already that
if you are kind of in the process of
negotiating a dispute you
[Music]
ideally should be able to kind of
pick and choose to an extent and not not
be totally didactic about about how you
apply these frameworks
i mean i guess i
i don't know how you analyze it then if
you're looking at it so holistically but
it's hard for me to imagine
any any one framework being able to
fully encompass kind of
all the possibilities of of a water
dispute
i think starting with a dispute
is um
going to get you into a corner you don't
need to be in
start with the fact that you need to
manage water
there's not a dispute you just you have
water and you have competing demands and
you have competing interests and you
have to manage the water
okay
what would be a good way
to manage the water
to involve
entities
with broad authority
or multiple authorities
or
narrow just water
to to involve
uh
only the most expert
people to make the decisions or to
engage
the stakeholders affected by
the decisions so there's support for
whatever
the decision is to go ahead with
would it make more sense to look just
narrowly at the water that you have
responsibility for because you're within
a political boundary or would it make
more sense to look at the water system
moving underground or above ground that
affects the water that you have
responsibility for
because the answers to those three kinds
of questions
almost always lead
to people saying
broader
linked more comprehensive more
participatory
more completely engaged because it it
seems like a better way to manage water
now
assume there's a dispute
within that water management system
how would you expect it to be resolved
well if you had
pulled in
all of those actors
and all of those interests and all of
that knowledge and all of that authority
to manage the water
and there was a dispute within that
you'd probably have to engage
all of those same elements in sorting
out a dispute
that emerged it would be hard to
to say oh there's a dispute now all of
you were involved in the planning of
this and the management of this go away
and the three of us will solve this
it's not going to happen
so iwrm isn't a dispute resolution
mechanism
iwrm is an approach to water management
and when disputes come up it's all
tangled up
in the dispute resolution
process
because
of what it took to do
iwrm as the planning as as the
management scheme
it's never it was never meant to be a
dispute resolution
strategy or mechanism
but it's tangled up
with efforts at dispute resolution
because it's kind of hard to shrink
any of the dimensions the parties the
interest the scope of the problem the
institutional powers
for purposes of resolving a dispute
that's come up within
the iwrm process
are there models i mean could you could
you differentiate and say and say the
um
you know the initial as you said any
any you know anyone who thinks through
the three questions you asked is gonna
move out and say you know broader more
inclusive greater scope for this could
you differentiate and say
okay the initial water management
uh considered like um you know
negotiations will will um kind of
exist on this macro level and
incorporate kind of many different kind
of facets of of of the economy and and
and kind of secondary tertiary effects
of water management but then you say
after that
you basically incorporate dispute
resolution processes that are hyper
local that that are specific to to kind
of the area where the where the
resolution or where the dispute is
taking place and don't require
you know completely remapping all of the
old terrain
that historically that's what the law
and regulation
have in fact done
right we have a
system of water rights
that has nothing to do
with iwrm i'll just take california or
take western united states iwrm
you would plan that water in a certain
way but you can't
in a system
that's defined
senior water rights
where people who got there first got the
water and then nobody can tell them what
to do with it and they can waste it they
can do anything they want it's
completely contrary to the ideas of iwrm
and
until relatively recently the whole
water law
around the world is not connected to
water management
the rules of water law come down almost
in the way aaron you're describing it
just how how can i localize this and
situate it in the way we deal with other
property rights
and that's how we'll handle the dispute
but it doesn't it doesn't fit
with what we imagine is the broader
scope and the need to take account of
more interest and the desire to look at
the interconnectedness of things and the
need to look ahead not back at who had
what rights but forward in terms of who
has what needs
and yet we're stuck with it
so
again iwrm
is a water management approach
it's it's easy to see how it evolved
and it seems perfectly logical
and it doesn't
it doesn't offer an obvious or easy way
of handling disputes over water within
systems that are managed by iwrm
and if you just try to solve this water
dispute in a purely legal fashion that
determines who has what senior rights
and hey that's it it's property
but that doesn't take account of water
as a shared
human resource or as a human right
and now how do we solve disputes over
the allocation of water we can't use
the property rights law
we need something else
[Music]
yeah that makes sense
and mitch how do you react to what i
just said
yeah i i um so in terms of a relation
with iwrm and water diplomacy i see that
um iwrm says um
according to iworm principle or
dimensions um water should be managed in
a
transboundary or watershed
or ecological boundary
so in that case i can see the
relation with the
and water diplomacy because
um
when i say that water should be managed
in a watershed or transboundary scale
that means it
definitely
[Music]
crosses boundary of
um
ecological boundary with the political
boundary and it can immediately creates
institutional mismatch and that can be
managed through uh diplo water diplomacy
uh
approach so that's how i can see
a relation with iowa so i can see auto
diplomacy can be useful
for the
um difficulties that have iwrm
implementation can be somehow um
implemented uh through incorporating
water diplomacy approach that's that's
how i feel um
uh the relation of iwrm and other
diplomacy
do you want to go to your next slide and
look at the
principles of iwrm explicitly in light
of the general discussion we've had yeah
yeah
yeah so
these are just a historical perspective
of iwrm so according to um
so it has started from the even
conference on water in mart del plata in
1977 then in 1992 um
dublin conference uh this is the main
building block for developing the iwrm
um
principles and in in this conference
these four principles has been
considered so the principle number one
is the
freshwater is finite and
vulnerable resources
essential to sustain life
development and the environment so here
you can compare
the uh thinking of the water diplomacy
so
it's completely um
opposite of the thinking of the dublin
principle where outer diplomacy
framework
considered water is the flexible
resource instead of
finite and vulnerable
resource so how
the conflicting situation can be um
um yeah can be considered as the
cooperative thinking
that can be a major shift of thinking in
terms of principles of iwrm and
water diplomacy so in terms of
principle number two
water diplomacy and management should be
based on a participatory approach
involving users planners and
policy makers at all levels
and another important principle is the
women should be a part of the
decision making
process like prohibition
management and safeguarding of water
specifically considering the role of
women in the developing country how they
are involved closely in work with the
water resource management and
uh yeah
services of the water resources
and the fourth and final principle is
that water has an economic
value in all its um
components
recognized as an economic
resource
so these are the four principles of
dublin um conference
in 1992
and then um
another event um where iwrm was first
established is um
second
world war from and ministerial
conference in the hague
where is considered the um
equity criteria um along with subsidiary
um
uh subsidies to poor this is also
considered as as a principle of iwrm
and then
it is declared in the international
conference on
freshwater in bonn
2001
and then world summit on sustainable
development in
2002
so
now um
based on this principles iwrm has been
as as you can see from the global water
partnership
definition that
iwrm is considered as a
process
which
promotes the coordinated development
and management of water land and related
resources
in order to maximize the resultant
economic and
social welfare in an equitable
manner
and without compromising the
sustainability of the vital ecosystems
so it it incorporates theoretically
multiple aspects like it's it's
considered as a planning process as um
larry already
mentioned and it incorporates the
coordinated
development like
tba kind of
development
pattern which incorporates not only
water resources
but also um water and related uh
resources that are linked with
water can be managed together
for maximizing the economic and
social
welfare with an equity
basis of
considering the sustainability of the
ecosystems
so that is the broader
definition of iwrm
and probably you have reading this um
uh criticism by uh asid visas
and um
uh where he mainly
criticized
the uh the the
vague definition of integration
what issues needs to be integrated
and how it can be a process
and um
so so in terms of operational point of
view um he identified this vagueness and
in terms of theory is fine but in terms
of implementation how this can be
applied in a given context this is
completely vague that's what his
message is
broadly regarding iworm
so uh we try to identify um
main dimensions of iwrm so these are the
dimensions that
in our um studies that we try to
identify so
first dimension is integrated
management
and the second dimension is the
[Music]
river basin or watershed should be the
special skill for managing water
resources
and um water governance or
um institutional um
mechanism for governing water is is very
important
and involving stakeholders and
public participations is also one of the
key dimensions of iwrm
and
consideration of water as an economic
good is is is a is an um
important
consideration of iwrm and also ensuring
gender equity and
uh
social
um yes social capital is is one of the
main uh
dimensions so these are the seven
dimensions of the iworm and um here i
can see as i i was mentioning that river
basin has a specialist scale
and
to um
implement this river basin for water
resources management it certainly
creates conflict and for managing that
water diplomacy can play
an important role for managing water
resources
for integrated management there are
criticisms that hot needs to be
integrated and that's also
depends on the um
specific
context and specific
context by engaging stakeholders what
issues needs to be integrated can be
decided and can be um
yeah um
it can be considered in a negotiation
table um
that can be part of the um
implementation part of the iwrm through
water diplomacy approach so that's how i
i consider that
uh for implementing iwrm the uh
criticism that has in the literacy some
of the
criticism can be overcome
uh when we consider the water diplomacy
approach that's that's how i see i don't
know um
larry what would be your opinion on the
linkage between isle of blue and water
diplomacy
well i i i thought your description was
very
reasonable
um
i'm i start with the problems in
practice
and maybe that's why i'm less tolerant
of some of the fuzziness and some of the
ambiguity in iwrm the way it's been
written about
um and the way it emerged
i mean calling water an economic good
leads to the notion that you should get
the prices right
if you want to protect the environment
if you want to protect the water
but as soon as you start talking about
getting the prices right
you're assuming water is a commodity
and if you think water should be a right
then the price is not relevant and
thinking of it as an economic good
is not helpful
and some of you know i i'm working on
the problem of water shutoffs
in american cities
where people who can't pay their bill
for their water for a month or two
have their water shut off
well
they can't pay their bill because
they're out of work and
telling them they have to pay their bill
isn't going to make it possible for them
to pay their bill
and then the next thing that the water
department does is it calls the family
services department and says take the
children out of that home there's no
water there it's that's not hygienic
so their kids are taken away
they still can't pay the bill
and then the next thing that happens is
the city puts
sells the lien
it's a economic instrument
on the on the debt
because the city needs money to pay to
maintain the water system and if people
don't pay their bills it doesn't have
the money it can't maintain the system
so it sells the debt
to private money lenders
who then
come after the person on a daily basis
and saying not only do you owe us the
900 from the last four months now the
interest rate and we've just increased
it to 10 interest
they can't pay the debt they can't pay
the interest
and then after a year the city says
we're going to sell your house
to recoup the
mounting debt
we have all kinds of
cities in the united states where the
water authority sells liens
and forecloses on homes all because
people couldn't pay
the fee for water
because they lost their job
now
we we have laws that don't allow the
electricity company to turn off
electricity in the winter if you can't
pay your bill because the presumption is
you'll die
but we don't have comparable laws that
say you can't shut off people's water
now during covid
very interestingly
we have had a moratorium on water
shutoffs in some cities
because now the presumption is people
have a good excuse for being unable to
pay their bills but before somehow they
didn't have an excuse like they lost
their job
this is all a function of thinking of
water as an economic good
what if we said
every residential property gets a
certain minimum amount of water that you
need to stay alive it doesn't cost
anything
and then
all the water above that
you pay a price relative to your ability
to pay
well we never had in the united states a
system of water fees based on ability to
pay
until last year when philadelphia passed
the first municipal law
saying that they wanted to move in a
different direction
and have people pay
for some portion of their water relative
to their ability to pay and you can
imagine the legal battle that's now
ongoing about whether that's okay or not
but all of that
is stems from the idea that water is a
commodity
and we should have to buy and sell it
in australia
when it
saw that it was running out of water
fresh water and had all terrible forest
fires and other difficulties
bought
as a government
all the water rights in one state
back from the owners
at a
prevailing price per
hectare
and then
it paid back the money by selling back
the water rights but on a different
basis to people
to try to have greater equity
in the availability of water
so it built a whole system
based on
water as an economic
good
in order to address a common need
where if we thought of water as a
natural resource and as a common
resource
pricing wouldn't be the focus
right
and we've tried to make a market out of
everything in the in the western
capitalist countries
and so now we have problems of water
being unavailable
to different groups of people
and i i worry that iwrm is about
maximizing
water as an economic good
that's one of the seven principles or
whatever that you had listed
what water's an economic good
um and
there are several of the principles i
understand completely where they came
from
but when i look in practice
the problem is we have under investment
in the capital
improvements necessary to get water to
people that need it
and there's not a way to solve that
through integrated water resource
management that's a political
ethical moral
decision
so
a lot of the conflicts some of which
don't rise to the level of a formal
conflict because the poor the
disadvantaged the marginalized don't
have the political clout to make it a
fight
but in fact there's a conflict
with very large numbers of people in
different parts of the world unable to
get adequate water because there's no
way to pay the capital cost
to build the desalination plant to build
the water movement system to get water
from one place to another
so that's what i worry about iwrm
causing
conflict and not providing a pathway to
resolution of conflicts given some of
the principles it includes
yeah
i i i had i had a different perspective
to what you just said for example if
um if a poor person in my country
uh doesn't have access to clean water um
he he's like installing a hand pump or
something at the cost of thousand
dollars or something it's an additional
burden to his daily income
uh what if the state state would have
provided him a water supply network with
a certain pricing and
the state had ensured that that water
was clean enough to drink like for
example i i in pakistan can't drink
water turkey from tap i'm not sure about
drinking water directly from the tap but
here in my
residence in ithaca
i drink water directly from tap
so
by this i'm saving money from the
bottled water
and then i'm saving money for installing
my own boring system or pumping system
so if the state provided me with clean
water with certain price in which they
are entering the infrastructure which is
lesser than the amount which i am
spending back home on bottled water and
boring
water
costs like
do well or something like that then
would you don't you think that the
approach would be most better the
pricing water pricing approach would be
better in this scenario
um you're paying rent in ithaca
that includes water cost
and if you lived in flint michigan
you would be paying
not that much different rent
but you couldn't drink the water from
the top
because it's been
allowed to become contaminated
and the city doesn't have the resources
to rebuild the whole
system so we've pushed on to individuals
the cost of getting water in some cities
whether we've allowed the water to
become contaminated
maintaining clean water
is a i would argue a common cost
not an individualized cost
while you can go buy water in bottles
we still expect the availability of
clean water from the tap
drinkable water that won't kill you
to be a common cost
if it's a common cost then we should
collect taxes from everybody in a
progressive way
and take care of building the things
that are common like
clean water system
so i know i i heard the comparison
you're making
but i would argue both in pakistan and
in the united states
that the responsibility of local
government should be
to provide
drinkable water for people
as a capital cost that's a collective
cost
and whether that cost is paid for from
taxes which could be collected in a
progressive way
or fees
which typically are not collected in a
progressive way
they don't look at ability to pay
i think we can have that debate about
what's the fair way to collect the money
but once the money is collected it
should be used to get everybody a
minimum amount of clean water that
that's my argument
yeah and i and i think that also fits
with the iwrm principle like social
equity and
uh yeah so
and and to add to your point that uh i
mean it is a iwrm is a collective
approach it's not about governments only
it's about people also society societal
education for example if you're doing
you just said use the word contamination
who is doing contamination we are doing
contamination we are uh mixing several
water with water we are doing water
thefts we are doing hole to the main
water supply line to get more water for
ourselves that is
something related to
the societal education
if we do not educate people that
water should be treated as a precious
resource that it should not be
contaminated it's like it's like a joint
responsibility not the responsibility of
government only
i agree i agree
um
you'll have to excuse me i'm trying
desperately
to get the folks planning glasgow
to
approach the problem in a different way
than they did in paris
and uh they have chosen this hour
uh at least i have a chance to talk to
them
i'm not making any progress this is the
third try uh but i i feel obliged
uh if they just meet in glasgow and do
again what they did in paris
we're doomed
and there has to be a different
discussion
and um there's a group of us who are
trying to promote a different global
discussion on this question
so i'm i'm going to disappear but the
the conversation
about iwrm
is important because you need each of
you
needs to formulate
to take a stand to formulate an idea
of
how you think water should be managed
and how you think disputes over the
management of water should be resolved
and i don't think
either animash or eye
thinks we know all the answers and i
don't think there's only one solution
for all places at all times
but we need to be thinking
prescriptively
and if the best language we could say is
uh
social needs are important
common good should be taken into account
water should be managed in a
comprehensive fashion
look at the linkage between water and
everything i don't think that
inspires action
or policy i think it's too vague
so i'm pushing you to think
in more
explicit prescriptive terms and then to
be able to argue for it for that view
before you leave can you just tell me
the questions you are going to address
in this meeting
yes what should be done before the
meeting
by the people who will be coming to the
meeting
while they can still formulate new
policy choices because once you're at
the meeting
all you do is argue about the text
that's been sent out and every 197
delegations have been sent there with
very explicit instructions by their
country there's no problem solving that
can happen at the meeting
but before the meeting everyone is busy
figuring out what they want
everybody else to do
there's no joint
planning beforehand that and because it
can't be done in an official way if it's
done an official way then everybody's
there reading the script from their
country saying everybody else is
responsible this is a problem that's a
problem
nothing can happen so we're trying to
get a different kind of conversation
amongst a substantial number
of the
people who will be at the conference
representing their countries into
conversations between now and the summer
not in their official capacity just
in terms of problem solving and not just
technical the others as well
but people said well how would you
decide who participates
and my argument is it doesn't matter
they're not going to decide anything
they're just going to put forward good
proposals let's just have a diverse
group that wants to put forward
proposals in the collective interest
well where would you have it
when would you have it i said it doesn't
matter we do it online we just need to
start work on new proposals of a
different kind and the question that i'm
saying that the proposal should be about
what help does your country need to get
to net zero by 2030 not what's your
responsibility for cutting stuff
what help
do you say you won't need to get to net
zero by 2030
and collect that and look at the
differences amongst what countries say
they want to need and then figure out
how different countries can help each
other
work toward that as the goal
2030 net zero that's what we have to aim
for
but now all we have is how much of the
over
run
will you agree to accept no matter what
it costs you
and the answer is you can't make me do
it
that's paris
and we're gonna get it again in glasgow
so that's that's what i'm the
conversation i'm trying to promote
forgive me yeah i will see you all next
week
so um
we wanted to say something uh
maybe quickly because we only have
i haven't been
there
i agree with the with larry's argument
that there should be a minimum
amount of water for every household or
every person instead of
putting them extreme pressure
uh through the capitalist system this is
a completely agree but at the same time
in my country i've seen and probably
have seen also that
when something is free
or whatever the amount that is when
something is free
most of the people and that has that is
i've seen from my observation and i'm
sure that the research if anyone
does it would
give the similar data
that when something is free there is a
tendency to waste
and
in bangladesh or in a in developing
country a huge number of people
they would be not that rich to afford it
so the government would be giving them
a massive amount of water in total
and and if everybody
wastes just a little or the majority of
the people waste just a little that's a
huge amount of water being wasted yes
because it's free and just because it's
free people do not evaluate that much so
i was thinking that how do we
make a mechanism to stop that is there
any mechanism at all so
that was my question
yeah i think the uh in terms of iwrm
principle the mechanism is there so
uh we need to um
place a price on the water and
yeah one equity basis the price
could be
different for different um
[Music]
uh group of people and that that can
help efficiency of water use and this
that is kind of demand side management
of water resources that is needed for
uh yeah um
increasing water water um use efficiency
so
yeah the
mechanism is there in terms of
theoretical aspect but for implementing
in bangladesh or in specific countries
is yeah
there are problems
so maybe now we can discuss water energy
and food nexus the
still we need to
so um
water energy and food
nexus this is another important paradigm
of water resources management sometimes
it's called separate paradigm but
sometimes it's
within integrated water resources
management where the integration
was vague in the iwrm and in this case
this sectoral integration is explicitly
mentioned
like i am integration of water energy
and food
but it could be also water energy food
climate water energy
um yeah um climate ecosystem
so it depends on the context but
the um
thinking of the
nexus is
it comes from system integration
um so how the global systems are
interconnected and
how um the
traditional siloa process um
is um
diminishing the importance of
system level outcome and that's that's
why the nexus
concept cam so for example um
uh if i ask you what you have eaten in
the breakfast maybe a banana
and in that banana is not only
food but also it incorporates
huge amount of water
um for
producing
the banana but also um transportation
um
and also um from the agricultural field
to coming into the
uh
food
breakfast
table it it it um consumes huge amount
of energy and if you um don't um
if you
waste that
banana then you can
um calculate how much energy and
water has also been
wasted from
producing to so this kind of thinking is
is the um
nexus thinking so if you can increase
the efficiency of water use in one
sector
that can also helps increasing
efficiency
in the energy sector and also food
sector and that that's how the water
energy food
nexus concept came not only in the
household perspective not only in the
urban aspect but also in the
transboundary water resources
management aspect
uh so the nexus uh concept builds on
many of these approaches and um
and it's it it also
incorporates this integrated process
i i already shared this article
probably you have um
read this article and it's it's
interesting because
it clearly identifies um the synergies
and trade-offs of um
of water resources
management within water energy and food
next and how
um
how the
incorporating nexus thinking can helps
increase the efficiency of water
resources
management
so
for example this nexus thinking uh can
uncover synergies up and
co benefits
the example that is
given in the um
london um
urine separation
technology
that helps reducing 10 percent of water
needs reduction
but um also eventually
this also um
helps reducing energy use in water
supply by 10 percent and
waste water treatment by 25 percent so
by using simple urine separation uh
technology
that uh this um helps
reducing um water needs um energy needs
and waste water
treatment need but also it helps
capturing nutrient for example um
2 300 tons of of phosphorus and 24 000
tons of nitrous and annually um can be
separated that can be utilized
for
producing a million tons of um
wheat in in uk so you you can see how
the
synergists and co-benefits can be
achieved by uh applying this water
energy food
um nexus approach
um but
also um it it can detect um harmful
trade-off
for example
uh in egypt
uh
and spain the water demand compression
uh is 75 percent higher than a span in
egypt
but
uh
because the in egypt it considers
gravity oriented irrigation system which
requires a mass water but at the same
time it can
the the energy the consumption is three
times lower than the spin because in
um
spend it
it um
it
considers not the
gravity regression but um
energy driven drip irrigation
system so if we convert the irrigation
system in um
in
egypt
then the water is saved but at the same
time the um
energy and carbon dioxide production
rate has increased significantly so this
kind of
trade-off can be considered by um
considering this um
nexus approach
and also um
um
i think
jimmy were uh was mentioning about the
biofuel and uh here is is the example of
biofuel um how the increased consumption
of
uh biofuel is promoted
as an alternative of oil and gas
but at the same time it it can clear
huge amount of water scarcity and food
food sustainability
in the united states but also in the
other countries so
um the the unexpected consequences uh
can be taken into account by considering
this
nexus approach
so um also in terms of integrated
planning and decision making and
governance this water energy food nexus
is very important
uh let's consider the trans-boundary
aspect
so here
uh in terms of water energy and food
nexus in the transboundary
context um if you see the
relation between water and food
and um for the um
food production you must need water
and
uh in the upstream um
water uses for the agriculture can
affects also in the downstream
and
this can so the water and food are
highly
really relevant in the transboundary
context but also
food affect water
resources for example um
it um can
through
intensifying agricultural practices and
land use
changes
by agricultural um
expansion this can affect water quantity
by changing the runoff but also it can
affect um eutrophication and and um
selenization um and affects water
quality
but at the same time um if you see the
relation between water and energy
for the energy production of course you
need um
water
and energy production also affects um
water quality and
quantity for example um
the
hydropower
production for energy affects on water
quality in terms of um
changing water temperature and and also
um so the water temperature can change
quickly by storing water in a in a
dam and that can also affect changing
the water quality parameter so does you
can see that this linkages are important
for um transboundary context in this
study um
done by the caskin and netel they try to
compare um
three um
trans-boundary areas uh in the central
asia mainly the aral sea
south asian context uh
ganza's brahmaputra and in the
mekong region the
and they try to
um
qualitatively analyze this interrelation
between the water energy and food
and the um
the the thickness of the
line can
determine how the relationship um
established and uh what are the strength
of the relationships uh
are um
determined by the thickness of the of
the um align for example in the case of
um central asia
the um
the the
the impact of food on water is highly um
important there but also impact of
energy
production on downstream order flow is
is also important
in the case of south asia the impact of
um
uh the the the
importance of water on agricultural
production between the episteme and
downstream is very important so that's
how they found so this kind of
uh qualitative
relationships for water resources
management within the water energy food
nexus has been established
so um in terms of
how the um
water energy food nexus is important for
water diplomacy so as as you have seen
that the
uh the identifying synergists and
trade-offs beyond water and um river
basin management skills is
provide an scope for water
um
diplomacy but but also the
mutual benefit and promoting value
creation the water energy food nexus
give a clear um
value added for um
for water and negotiation for example
hydropower
linking hydropower
agricultural production and and
water
management can helps achieving um
um
can helps
creating multiple benefits and multiple
co-benefits and multiple value that
helps
water
negotiation very
easily but but also um water energy food
nexus promote
um business idea and that can also uh
linked into the negotiation
table and can can help reducing the um
the the
conflict and can
can be
can create a cooperative environment so
these are the ideas that
uh water energy food nexus can support
um promoting the water or diplomacy
that's how i see so uh here is a
reference i i'll put them in the
canvas site i found just recently so i
can share this um article so that you
can understanding how our energy food
nexus can be um
useful for water
diplomacy and also how water diplomacy
can help
implementing water energy food nexus
approach
just
quickly um sustainable
development goals um you know the
sustainable
development uh goal has been um
considered in 2015 to meet the
target by 2030 and in order to move from
m disease to s disease
uh it considers 17 s disease and
with 169
targets and
and sdg 6 um
is um though
ensuring availability and sustainable
management of water
and sanitation for all and it
incorporates sdg 6.5 that um
we need to implement iwrm um through
transboundary cooperation so the the
goal um
6.5
or target 6.5 specifically on
implementation of iwrm for um
for
cooperation uh incorporating
transboundary
cooperation
so uh here is the linkage of s disease
and and um
iwrms but but also
the way iwrm is um considered as a as an
indicator
um it it it's kind of there is
[Music]
criticism on this because iwrm is very
broader concept and theoretical concept
but the way the iwrm is considered as
even
sustainable goals there are a strong
criticism on that because it considers
very vague way of
putting numbers on iwrm and how they
measuring the
progress is is very um
uh yeah it's very
debatable but you know
this is one of the
major paradigm that um internationally
acknowledged
and and um
that's why um iwrm is very important and
also um
with
relation to um
s disease and water diplomacy i see that
many hdc goals are interlinked and it
can clears um synergies and trade-offs
so for example if i can meet one
sdg target
for example renewable energy production
and for the renewable energy production
uh it's not um
specifically um
defined uh which kind of renewable
energy can be produced so that can
promotes idea of um
um
hydroelectric uh
electricity
generation so that
can also affect
implementation of um iwrms because if
you
promote um
upstream order development projects for
hydroelectricity then
this can affect a relationship
with them
with the downstream
countries so this kind of synergies and
trade-offs are very important and that
can be um reduced or that can be
resolved through our diplomacy approach
broadly so that's how i can see the link
between the this disease and and um
and what are diplomacy aspect in in
general so
that's that's um we wanted to um discuss
today classes so first we already
discussed the
evolution of water resources management
uh how it came from the supply side
approach to the um
demand and um decentralized approach
with an example but then we already
discussed
uh iwrm and its importance um in the
um international water resource
management aspect and its
relation with the water diplomacy but
also we discussed um
water energy food nexus and sustainable
development goals and its
relation with water diplomacy
yes so the next class will be the week
after and in that class we will play a
role play simulation
practically how we can resolve
water conflicts
uh
we'll play the game endopotomia river
basin management and for the role plus
simulation uh we will need 9 players
but we have 6 players
so
do you know is there any of your friend
could be interested in the role place
simulation um if if you don't find i
will try to find three other players but
yeah if you have
uh
yeah interesting um
uh colleagues that are
highly interested to the to understand
the role play game you can
let me know yeah
so another um
notice our announcement is that
next week um larry and me are going to
talk on transboundary water resources
management larry will discuss mainly the
theoretical aspect and i will describe
the um
uh brahmaputra riverbasin case so if you
are interested you
you can
join in this event i can share the link
for the registration it's the um
eu time so it's the european time
so
in
u.s time is could be 11 11 a.m or yeah
so if you are interested you you feel
free to join this in this event
yeah
another announcement sorry i wanted to
put in the put it in here
there is a discussion paper on
water energy and food nexus
and um
there is a discussion series is um
taking place by one of our
colleague who is the editor of the
journal
water um hydrological sciences
journal
and in that discussion paper there is a
topic on water energy and food nexus and
if you are interested and if you feel um
is fit in your area of interest
there is a paper on water quality and
water energy food nexus
and if you can criticize or um
comment on that paper that can also be
published um if this is a
concise and
and um yeah in a written in a scientific
way so i can share that link if you are
interested in participating this kind of
um
writing
you can let me know i i have the link
with the editor of that
journal so i can share with you um if
you are interested so the write-up
should be one or two page
but it should be written in a scientific
way
yeah
so i i will share those two links and
also i will share the
role place simulation um
uh what the general instruction but also
confidential instruction for his player
i i'll share with you in next few days
so
bye